You are listening to
radiolab radio from W and y.
S e
n n p r phone. Oh, you know what,
will you forgive me if I actually
leave my phone on vibrate because, uh,
my wife is pregnant and due
literally really any day.
No kidding. If this vibrates, I might
ruin your radio program, but no,
it's fine. It's all worse.
So recently I had a conversation
with this Guy Josh for,
he's a journalist science journalist and
he told me about something that's been
obsessing him recently. This
very odd experiment. Well, okay,
so this is uh, one of the longest
running science experiments of all time.
The pitch drop experiment.
You can actually see it
online. How do I get to it?
I had just started her pitch
drop, pitch drop. So a,
you can also go radiolab.org
we have got the live feed, uh,
right there on the website and what you
will see is this funnel list of black
stuff in it. And then, uh,
descending from the stem of the funnel
is this little tendrils of this black
stuff.
And at the end of that tendril as a little
teardrop of this black stuff that's,
it doesn't move, do anything.
But according to Josh, sure. Pitch
drop junkies all over the world.
People who are just, I've got this
open in the background on their,
on their web browser and he says they
all just sit there watching and waiting.
And that's the thing. Once you
understand what's going on here,
you kind of can't look away. Okay.
So here's what happened
in 1927 there is this guy,
Thomas Cornell who is teaching physics
at the University of Queensland and in
Australia and he's trying to
show his students that, um,
well I guess that things aren't
always what they seem. Okay. Uh,
and so he takes a chunk of this material
and called pitch. What's pitch? Okay,
so pitch is a natural substance. In fact,
this is actually really the question.
What is pitch? Well, what does it
look like? It's like, is it gooey? No,
that's the thing. It's like a rock.
You can break it with a hammer and it
shatters into a million little pieces,
but it's not a rock.
It's a viscoelastic polymer
fisco elastic polymer,
which means that over many,
many, many, many years,
it moves really the,
what he did was he melted a handful of
pitch and poured it into a glass funnel
and once it did properly settled,
he snipped the bottom
of the funnel and waited
for what? Well, for it to drip.
You mean drip like a faucet would
drip? Yeah, but much, much more slowly.
So 1930 Pluto is discovered.
Bonnie and Clyde mean phone love going
to crimes where you get killed by the
police. 31 the empire state
building is finished. It'll drip.
1933 the Nazis build their
first concentration camp
prohibition and still hasn't
driven five Amelia Earhart fly solo
across the Pacific Ocean. Are you kidding?
No drip. 1936 5 million barrels of
cement turning to the Hoover dam.
No drift for eight years. This rock
is slowly, slowly, slowly stretching.
He's into this dangling drop
and then suddenly one day,
eight years after he poured the damn
thing into the funnel and the 10th of a
second, the blink of an eye.
Oh, the pitch breaks.
Nobody's ever actually seen
this happen. I mean it's never,
there's drop has never dripped. No, no.
The drop is gripped eight times and we're
all due for the ninth drop to happen
any day now. So wait,
why haven't they seen it?
So imagine a a science experiment, right?
Where the critical data that you want to
gather happens in one 10th of a second
every 10 to 12 years.
It is really hard to be there
at that critical moment. Yes.
Yeah. This fellow professor John Mains,
then he's been watching it religiously
since January of 1961 for 50 years.
I am still waiting to see miss pitch
drop just at a suspense or is there some
question here? Well
first of all, well, okay,
the question is moment when you this
ever elongating droplet gives way.
What happened if you've got the drop
itself hilled by four little fibers,
call them fibers. What breaks
first? How does it break?
And there are lots of people who like me,
are waiting to see whether we can capture
that moment and see the way in which
from a mechanical point of view it becomes
imperative that the dropped in fall,
so 1962 mainstay and Mr.
Drop in 62 August,
1971 April of 1979 tat one
he looked at on a Friday.
I knew it was close and thought, well
something might happen over the weekend.
Came in on a Saturday, Saturday
evening, checked to pitch job,
nothing happening.
I'm going home and by the time I came
in very early on the Monday morning,
not having gone in on
Sunday, it had fallen.
Then 1988 he standing right there
and I decided I need to cover teams.
Something like that. Walked
away, came back, oh no.
And low and behold he thinks he may have
missed it by as little as 15 minutes
had dropped. Now you take your tee and
throw it against the wall and rage. Yes.
Well, yes.
One becomes a bit philosophical
about this and I just,
oh well let,
let's be patient the next time
he installed the camera and,
and then, and then 28 November,
2000 is what happened.
Then the time I was over on the other
side of the world in London gets an email
saying, professor this [inaudible] drop
looking as though it might fall in time.
We've been waiting 10 years
for this. It's about to happen.
Cause it was like I said, don't worry,
we've got it covered. Got a camera on it.
I'll be able to see exactly what
happened when I get back to Australia.
The next email said, well it's dropped.
Wow.
Later that day, do you professor
mains then I've got bad news.
Unfortunately you will not be able to
see this because the system failed.
The camera went out, the camera went
out. We don't have this on record.
Come on. So that was one of
my satisfied, I might say. Uh,
but right now the pitch is getting
ready to give birth to another drop.
And this time there are three
cameras, three webcams on there.
And this is what Josh was showing
me on the Internet. This ling little
almost that all is people are watching
people from China, South America.
You knew what people were helping the
north of Canada. Everybody's waiting.
Everybody wants to be the
person who sees the pitch fo
and got to admit, I've been
checking this thing online.
Like were you like watching
grass grow? I don't know. It's,
I think it's more than
suspect. I think that this is,
it's about timescale is what it's about.
We don't really have that
many opportunities to interact
with things that happen
on these two very, very different
timescales simultaneously.
Huh? Do you see what he means? Yeah.
Cause you know you're
in this funny situation.
You wait slower than you know how for
something to take place that's faster than
you can, you know, catch. Exactly.
So you're playing at the very
edges of what you know how to do,
but not if you catch it,
then you get this glimpse into this
world that's usually unknowable.
Exactly.
So for the next hour,
we're going to mess around with
this idea because you know,
we're humans and we live in a human scale,
but we've got a bunch of stories
that are gonna ask us to stretch
that scale to the breaking
point. Yeah, I'm Jad Abumrad.
I'm Robert Krulwich today on radio lab
speed wait,
things keep getting faster and then
faster again and then faster and faster,
faster,
faster and faster and faster and faster
and path until we get to the fastest
thing in the universe and stop
bit cold. But before we do that,
quick update,
some happy news and a bit of sad news
about that pitch drop experiment.
First up, the drop finally dripped
and it was caught on camera this time.
And you can uh, watch that moment in time
lapse@radiolab.org. Now the sad news, uh,
professor mainstone missed it again
after 52 years of watching over that tar
field beaker waiting,
he died without ever
actually seeing a drop fall.
But on the bright side, I guess
the experiment is still going.
The 10th drop is expected to
fall sometime in the next 14.
So in honor of him,
keep an eye on that live feed and a
few supervision. You might just, you,
okay. So let's set the baselines
here. How fast are our we,
you mean like how fast we run? I mean,
how fast do we interact with
the world around us? Uh,
how fast do we taste things? How fast
do we feel something? See something.
Respond. Hello? Oh, hello. Hey there.
Hey, how do we sound? That sounds better.
Much better. Excellent.
That's Carl Zimmer of course,
science writer regular around here. And
he told us that question you just asked.
How fast do people, humans
processed the world?
That question popped up in a really big
way around 1850 with the invention of
the telegraph because suddenly you
could send a message across the country
almost instantly.
If you're in New York and you
want to send a message to Chicago,
money stopped.
It's gonna take about a quarter of a
second for that message to get there.
That's 790 miles in a quarter. Second.
Now that's really fast. In
fact, if you do the math,
790 times,
four times 60 times 60 it's
11 million miles an hour.
That's amazingly fast. So fast.
In fact that some people when
they first used the telegraph,
they just refuse to
believe that it was real.
Cause in 1850 you're doing oh
35 40 miles an hour on a horse.
60 maybe on a steam engine up to
80 you're not living too fast.
But more importantly for our story, the
Telegraph got people thinking about us,
about our bodies, right?
Cause you know nerves and telegraph
wires are remarkably similar.
Nerves are long and skinny. They carry
electricity from one place to another,
just like a telegraph wires. So
naturally people wanted to know,
well if telegraph wires can
do millions of miles an hour,
well what about our nerves?
How fast are they? Exactly.
And so one day a German
guy biologist named
Herman von Helmholtz took a frog cause
their neurons are kind of like ours.
And basically what he did was he,
he hooked some wires up to one of
the frogs muscles. Now, this was,
I should tell you a dead frog,
but he sent an electrical jolt through
the muscle and then using a very fancy
timer, he was able to determine, yeah,
the signal was going down the length
of the a frog muscle at a speed of 27
meters per second. What does that
in miles per hour per se. Um,
let's see. I can, uh, Google,
actually it's, I love Google.
Um, 27 meters per second is 60.3,
nine, seven three miles per hour.
16.3 miles per hour. Wait, this is a
frog. Is this the same speed? Not Yes.
60 miles an hour. That
seems so slow. Yeah.
What's the name of the Jamaican
runner? The fastest guy in the world.
Hussein bolt. Usain bolt.
So it was saying bolt is running at half
the speed of his nervous system. Okay.
But, but, but in bear
mind actually, I mean, uh,
there's a big range of speeds of your
neurons and actually Hussein bald is much
faster than some of your neurons. I mean,
there are some neurons that only go about
a mile an hour. Which ones are those?
Ironically, some of them are from
the reward centers of your brain.
Chocolate travels slowly. Yeah, relatively
slowly. What about pain? I mean,
that would, that would be fast.
I imagined. Yeah, you'd think so.
But pain actually runs kind of
slowly. I was surprised to learn.
He says it can be as slow as 1.3
miles an hour. Wait a second.
So if I put my hand near a
candle and then I go, ouch.
Shouldn't that happen very fast? Look,
I mean, if you were like 70 miles tall,
this might be a problem.
Okay. But still, I mean,
what if we just take a really ordinary
example like Robert Looking at the desk
in front of him and grabbing that
pen? What's involved? Yeah. Well,
I mean you just essentially need
to kind of walk through this brain.
[inaudible] you start
at the I. Okay. So, uh,
the eye takes the light that's
reflected off the [inaudible].
Penn turns it into a little electrical
signal and then sends that deep into the
middle of the brain,
takes a couple of hundred 72nd bounces
around for a bit and then within few
more, hundreds of a second.
The signal has made it all the way back
to the rear end of the brain where you
start processing vision. But this
is just the beginning right now.
You've got to like figure
out what you're seeing.
So our joke is off again this time toward
the middle of the brain and then down
toward the bottom to these other
regions that start to decode the signal,
the first visual regions
called v one next up,
v two before and so on, and
they're going to sharpen the image,
make out contrast edges,
and then the electricity goes back
towards the front of the brain after,
let's see, another 10th of a second or so.
We finally get to a place where we think,
oh, that's a pen we haven't gotten you to.
I want it exactly
for that to happen,
the electricity has to jump from one part
of the front of the brain to another.
And another before you can finally say,
that's a nice pen. I could use a pen
and we're still not done, you know,
then you then then little jolt heads
nor to sort of the top of your brain.
So we've,
we've gone from the your eyes to the
back of your brain around up to the front
of your brain again.
And now we're up to the top of your
head where you set up motor commands
and then you can grab the pen. Christ.
So I mean
you add all this up and what
are we talking about here?
About a quarter of a second quarter
of a say feels like one month later,
rubber town begin slowly to move toward.
The object is design quarter of a size.
So that's the same amount of time.
It takes a telegraph to send a message
from New York to Chicago. Yeah.
So your eyes, your hand,
New York, Chicago. Oh Man.
The sad truth has Carl, is
that our neurons, when it
comes to communicating and,
and sending signals on your answer,
they're terrible actually. I mean,
compared to our, you
know, broadband networks,
particularly when one neuron
bumps into the next one,
there's actually a little space between
them. So the signal to get across,
it's got jump
and then jump to the next
one and jump and then jumped.
It's Kinda like doing
hurdles. It's not smooth.
And the spooky part about
this slowness says, Carl,
the deeper thought here is
that if you think about it,
because we have this built in delay
in processing the outside world,
everything that I'm
experiencing already happened.
[inaudible]
you know how like you look out
at the stars and you think, oh,
that light's been traveling for
thousands, millions of years to get to me.
And what's happening on that star to the
planet around that star right now does
even still exist.
Um, you can say that about
everything around you
because I mean by the time that you
become aware of something in front of you,
it's been sitting there for
awhile, relatively speaking.
I'm stuck in the past, but it's, it sounds
like if you want to be in the moment,
then what you do is you stare up at the
sun and you let the light just be light
entering your eyes and you don't
think anything about the light.
You don't try and comprehend the
light. You just let the light be light.
And that's as close as you're
going to get to now. Yeah.
Well you're looking at old light. Uh, but
yeah, it's eight minutes.
Like even if you switch, you know,
even if you switch on the light and you're
looking at the light bulb across the
room, it's old light because
it had to go from your eyes,
through your brain to you to be
aware that there was light there.
So what I would suggest is that you close
your eyes and you stop thinking about,
you know,
the chair you're sitting in and just
focus on your own thoughts because that's
the fastest stuff you've
got to, it's right there.
You don't have to wait for it to
be deliberate into your brain.
It's already in your brain.
So I think your thoughts are the
fastest things that you can experience.
So my fastest thought that
I can ever have is okay,
where I'm my key.
You've got to have faster thoughts
than that with the faster one.
This is an interesting question though.
I think it would be non narrative.
I don't think it can be a
keys or something. I think
it would just be like a,
ah, someone has thought about this.
What? It wasn't me because I had no idea.
Don't you think somebody has an answer
for us on this? Uh, hello. Hello. Hello.
In fact, we found a guy, his name
is Seth Horowitz. I am the a,
he's a neuroscientist, author
of the Universal Sense.
How hearing shapes the mind.
So we were talking, uh, with,
and we ran set through
the question, you know,
if we're all trapped in the past by
the slowness of our nervous system,
what would be the most present the
most in the now that we could be? Well,
if you are any actually disagreed
with Carl's gas. He said,
even if you think the simplest thought
that it is possible to think it's
probably still going to be on the order
of a quarter of a second half second.
Oh Man. You have to get away from
the conscious brain. No thinking,
no seeing hearing is the fastest
sense because mechanical,
it normally operates on the millisecond
range. Thousandth of a second,
a sudden loud noise activates a very
specialized circuit from your ear to your
spinal neurons. You mean and bypasses the
brain? Yeah, it's the startle circuit.
If you suddenly hear a loud
noise within 50 milliseconds,
50 thousands of a second, so you
talking 20 times faster than cognition,
your body jumps. We'll begin
the release of adrenaline.
No consciousness involved. It's five
neurons and it takes 50 milliseconds,
50 milliseconds. So you're
already getting into a faster,
much faster paradigm by using sound.
So if we're going to jilt ourselves
as close to the president as possible,
then we'd have to play a
really loud noise, right? Like,
okay,
wait for it. This.
I know. That was annoying. I'm
no, I know. But look, thing we do,
we just did together. We were all in the
moment, in the present tense together.
Not Quite, not as we now understand
that we were just shy just to,
it's he bits shy of the moment time.
If I spoke fast enough for me
to say thank you to Carl Zimmer,
they could have said hardwoods
and now I've got to break.
There's no way you could even form the
thug. Thank you. In 50 milliseconds.
But I tell you what, in this
next, in this next segment,
we're going to make 50 milliseconds
feel like 50 years. Oh, that's a really,
really nice promo there.
That'll make everybody lean in.
That's actually a terrible like there
[inaudible]
sort of message. Hi,
this is Joshua for calling in the
middle of the Congo Louise Rainforest.
This is Carl Zimmerman. I'm going
to read you the credits. Um,
I'm going to, uh,
I'm gonna read you the credits
slow and then fast. So, um,
thank you.
I'm a little bit supported in part by
the Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing
public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
[inaudible] on that word alone.
That O r g lab is pretty
federally NYC able to do by MDR.
Okay, well I hope that helped you guys.
Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich.
Radiolab is supported by Sofi,
a new kind of finance
company. Here's the deal,
if you've invested in your career
by taking out student loans,
Sofi wants to help out sofi, refinances,
federal and private student loans to cut
interest rates and save its members an
average of $316 a month.
Learn more and find
savings@sofidotcomtermsandconditionsapplyatsofi.com
slash
legal
hey guys, this is Alison
calling from Luxembourg.
Radiolab is supported by rocket
mortgage by quicken loans.
Rocket mortgage brings the mortgage
process into the 21st century.
With this completely online process,
safely share your bank statements and
pay stubs with the touch of a button.
Ditch the paperwork and use your phone
or tablet to get approved for purchase or
refinance in minutes.
Get a custom mortgage solution
whenever and wherever you want.
Check out rocket mortgage
today@quickenloansdotcomslashradiolabequalhousinglenderlicensedinallfiftystatesandnlsconsumeraccess.org
number 30 30 hi,
I'm Robert Krulwich. Radiolab is
supported by Google and Squarespace.
Make your business official
with Google and Squarespace.
When you create a custom domain and
a beautiful business website with
Squarespace, you'll receive
a free year of business,
email and professional tools from Google.
It's the simplest way to
look professional online.
Visit squarespace.com/google
to start your free trial.
Use the offer code document for
10% off on your first purchase.
Google and Squarespace. Make it
professional. Make it beautiful.
Ready? Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad.
I remember Krulwich.
This is Radiolab and bead is
our subject. Keep me doing it.
That's what this whole
next segment is about. See,
I had it in my bones just to set it up a,
I got this idea from my friend Andrew's
Ali, who is a fantastic writer,
wrote the book, uh, resilience. Why
things bounce back. We were at a diner.
I was telling him about
this show and he says,
you should do something about
the stock market. And I was like,
I'm the last person should do is in the
most dogmatic. He's like, no, no, no,
no. Forget everything you think you
know about the stock market. Um,
most of us, when we think
about stock markets,
if you just close your eyes and you
think about the financial world,
what you imagined,
there's a bunch of people in a room
and they're all wearing funny colored
jackets and they're
shouting at each other and
waiving bits of Pavia,
right? 70, this kind of
Rawkus Watson, it's white
gay people screaming,
trying to figure out what a crisis, and
we'll have this sort of iconography,
this cultural iconography of
how the financial system works.
That is in large part complete
lead divorced from reality because
he told me, here's my first surprise,
that somewhere between 50 and 70 plus
percent of all the trades that happen on
what we think of as Wall Street are not
executed by a human being as a result of
a human decision.
They're actually executed by an algorithm
at a speed rate and scale that is
beyond our comprehension.
So I decided I would try and
comprehend this new world that he was
describing.
And since this is a subject matter
that generally makes me frightened,
frankly, I decided to call up David
Kestenbaum from planet money. Hey Jed.
Hello? V David Casto. Indeed
there could be more than one.
They probably are on Twitter. In any
case, it did not click for either of us.
Just how fast, how humanly
fast trading had gotten. Yeah.
Until we visited this firm called trade
works. Hi David. Nice to meet you David.
So we go into this little
building in New Jersey.
It looks like it's a startup or
something and uh, this guy says,
hello, my name is Mike Dollar. I'm the
chief technology officer of trademarks.
And Mike over here sat
us down at this computer.
Opened up would be this little program
that logs exactly what is going on at the
market representation of insanely
specific times. You could pick a stock.
Um, we could look at,
um, Yahoo for example.
We can literally pick some time
of day that we're interested in.
What time is this? So it's what time?
So this is at 1135 26.979 seconds.
And in fact,
that's not enough precision for us
because we really deal in micro seconds.
That would be millions of a second. So
we have another way of measuring time,
which is the number of microseconds
since midnight of the previous day.
Can you read that? 407
number. Sure. 41 billion.
729,979,559 microsecond since midnight.
Wow. So do you always have lunch at like
2,000,305,000 without,
that'd be really early.
[inaudible]
hi. How many trays do you do in a day?
Um, I think it depends a lot. Uh,
a high frequency trader might
do thousand trades in a minute.
[inaudible]
it's about that tempo, but
it's kind of very bursty
now what happens during those
bursts is a bit of a mystery.
It's very hard to see what's
going on. Often says, Andrew,
it's the computers testing the market
testing to see if they can find a nibble
on the other side.
They'll fire out a bunch of buy and sell
orders and then when another computer
bites on one, they'll quickly cancel
the ones that didn't stick. Nope. Sorry.
Didn't want to do that. And they're doing
this on a microsecond basis by, nope,
sorry, sal. Nope, nope, nope,
nope. Forget about that by na,
and they create huge volumes
of transactions that just
disappear into the ether.
There are some computer
algorithms he says,
whose whole job is to combat other
algorithms, fake them out. For example,
we just a very good example, it
happened about a month ago in craft.
That's Eric Han. Sandra. He tracks
high frequency trading for the,
from Nanux craft like Kraft
cheese crap. Yes. He says,
what they saw was this
algorithm jumping in the market,
buy up a bunch of craft
which jam the price up,
which allowed that algorithm to sell
at much higher prices to 'em the other
algorithms and we calculate
it out. It costs them 200,000
to push the price up,
but they were able to sell about 900,000
of stock and netting again of of over
half a million dollars
in the matter of seconds.
Now to put that in context,
back in the day, you know,
20 years ago when the humans still ran
the trading pits [inaudible] according to
this guy, I'm Larry Tab, founder
and CEO of the TAC group.
The average time that it took to execute
a trade was around 1112 seconds back
then and when you ask people how did we
get from 11 or 12 seconds to forty one
million seven hundred twenty nine million
nine hundred seventy nine thousand
five hundred fifty one like a second.
Since we like phrases like that,
the answer is kind of surprising, but
I'll just start with the obvious part.
At least the part that's obvious
to people who work in finance.
It wasn't obvious to me,
but a basic law of the market is that
the fastest person will usually win.
There's always a benefit.
That's Andrew again,
to getting information faster
than the other guy. Absolutely.
This has been going on since
Julius Reuters used carrier
pigeons to send a bunch
of stock quotes faster
than guy on a horseback,
and that was in the 1850
here's a more modern example. Say
the latest job numbers come out.
US Employers added
227,000 jobs in February.
If those numbers are good, that means
the stock market is going to go up.
So if you can get the numbers and rush
to the market before anyone else gets
there and buy the stock before it goes up,
you could make a lot of money right
on the, you know, buy low sell,
high principle, basic
law of, of getting rich.
But when the market's turned electronic,
which began to happen in the
early nineties this basic
law created a situation
that was totally bananas.
What do you mean?
So imagine it's the year 2000
you've got this market in New York,
it's electronic. It's basically
just a building on broad street,
near Wall Street with a giant computer
inside of it that's matching buyers and
sellers and you have a bunch of traders
in different parts of the country that
are connected to this market,
to this building and a,
some of them are using a automated
trading bots and one day this Guy Dave
Cummings who is in Kansas notices
that his robot keeps getting beat.
Like when it would send
a trade to New York,
like say a buy order often right as that
buy order was about to get to New York,
some other robot would swoop in and get
their first and snatch up the trade and
it occurs to this Guy Dave, wait a second,
is it cause I'm in Kansas if the other
guys closer to New York than his cable
boots
shorter. So I need to move
to New York. No, no, no.
Cause we're talking
about the speed of light.
Well close to the speed
of light knowledge. No,
obviously it's because he's
in Kansas. What do you mean?
Obviously cause the speed of light
is like a foot and nanosecond.
You're going to get your ass
kicked if you're in Kansas.
I don't even know how you know this for
a fact. Yeah, it's a foot in nanosecond.
It's a foot and nanos it takes a
billionth of a second. Go a foot.
It's three times 10 to the 10
something something. Everybody
knows. I know this because
when I was in physics,
like if I needed to delay a signal by
a nanosecond by billionth of a second,
I just added an extra foot of cable.
And then did you really do that? Yeah.
Cause the Proton antiproton would collide
and then it would create a mew on that
would go out and you only wanted to
measure, you want to filter all the junk.
So you knew when it was
going to arrive, roughly.
So you had a little like window I
had to arrive and then the window.
But you had to get the
timing of the window. Right.
So it meant like adding a delay and
we just would add cable and it was the
easiest way to add.
So would literally go get some
from cable and just splice it in,
not splice it Lima there lemo
connectors will connect. Of course.
Here's another way to think about it,
like say the time it takes for information
to get from Kansas to New York is
something like this. Did
you hear that? I did.
First piece is when it leaves Kansas.
Second beep is when it
arrives in New York. Yes.
Actually slowed that down just
a bit so we can hear it better,
but the point is that is fast,
but there's still a little space
in there between the beeps,
which is the travel time.
Very, very little space,
but even if these signals are
traveling at millions of miles an hour,
close to the speed of light,
if somebody is a few hundred miles closer
to New York than you and they leave at
the same time as you will,
then it's going to be like
you hear that but it a yeah,
that beep in the middle of some other
dude beaten you by a few milliseconds.
These little differences
matter that they're trying
to get in and out super fast
and maybe each trade, they're
only making a fraction of a penny.
That's it says Andrew.
But if you're making a fraction of a
penny millisecond after millisecond after
millisecond can add up. Right? But you
have to be able to react really fast.
So when this guy in Kansas decided
to move his robot to New York,
get closer to the big market
computer, when this happened,
it started kind of a land grab.
There was a real estate bubble around
some of these buildings because people
were trying to buy physical real estate
next to the exchanges so that the cables
that they would run into the exchanges
would be just a few feet shorter than the
other guy.
Wait a second. So,
so does this mean like if I'm like one
stop up on the elevator and you're two
stops up that I have the, the,
the, the second floor advantage.
I mean how far do you do
this? Theoretically? Yeah.
I mean that's what it means.
But
I don't know how far this real estate
jockeying got because pretty early on the
the people who run the market
stepped in and they were like, okay,
this could get crazy. So they
told the machine traders, okay,
you want to be close to us,
fine, pay us some money,
we'll let you come inside. Inside our box,
inside the mothership.
Is there like some room or
all these computers or are
keeping each other company
now? Oh are they asked? There is, if you
visit the New York Stock Exchange now,
which we did after going through
months of security checks,
what you see is amazing.
Say so this is why the
20,000 square foot home,
this is Ian Jackie's head
of infrastructure at the
New York Stock Exchange.
He showed us around
with a number of rows of
racks for customer payments.
In 2006 New York Stock
Exchange opened up this room.
It's the size of three football
fields filled with nothing but
by embracive of service. A different
specific, so these are owned by banks?
Hedge funds brokers, yeah. Oh,
number of financial institutions.
Are these things training
right now? Absolutely.
Each of these computers and there
were close to 10,000 in the room,
give or take. Where at that
moment analyzing the market,
making a decision as to
whether to buy herself,
sending that decision over a cable into
an adjacent room where it gets bought or
sold. Yeah, no people involved. If
you stood still for a few seconds,
the lights went out, they
automatically went off. If not,
they moved because the assumption was
that we're not going to be people there.
And the whole idea of
this place says again,
the whole premise is
a level playing field.
So any firm can come in here and they
will have the same access as anyone else.
And to make sure of
that, my favorite part,
every single rack within this facility
has the same length of cabling to get to
the network points at the end and exactly
the same length. Exactly the same.
Yep.
Everybody gets the same length cabling.
Whether you're one foot away from the,
you know, network hub or a thousand
feet away, you get the same links.
I'm sure they send synchronized
test pulses from both your,
your trading computer and
jazz trading computer,
and they make sure they arrive
exactly at the same moment.
I like to imagine they have a guy with a
tape measure. That's the guy you bribe.
That's the guy. Anyhow,
you would think that since all machines
can now be inside the exchange,
literally inside the market building,
that the speed race would be over, right?
Yup. No,
actually it only gets worse
because the place we visited,
the New York Stock Exchange, it's just
one market. Many, I didn't know this,
but apparently when all trading went
electronic, the market's fragment,
it used to be that the trade stocks
there was the New York Stock Exchange and
then there was Nasdaq. Really
just those two markets is Larry.
Now there are 13 regulated exchanges.
There are roughly 50 what they call dark
pools in the marketplace is they're not
in public, basically. Yeah,
so you've got these 60 some odd different
markets and that's created all these
different speed races between them.
Yet, here's a super basic example. Well,
I talked about with Andrew
Actually in Chicago.
You've got this thing called
the commodities market.
Commodities are basic goods like corn oil,
soy beans, zinc, pork. That's
what they do in Chicago.
Here in New York we do equities
and equity is a share of a company.
So you have basic goods in Chicago,
stocks of companies in New York.
Those are different kinds of things, but
they're connected to each other. Right.
You know, cause like take oil,
which is traded in Chicago.
A lot of companies depend on oil
and they're traded in New York.
So say oil goes up in Chicago,
you can pretty much bet that right after
that a company like Exxon is to go up
in New York, but it won't
be instantaneous. Right.
Because information has a speed back
in the days of the Telegraph as we've
learned,
it took a quarter second about that
long to get from New York to Chicago.
Now with fiber optic cables, about 15
milliseconds. I love that. I had no idea.
You could actually hear
the time difference.
That one I think is pretty accurate. 15
milliseconds. But say you're in Chicago,
oil goes up,
you know it and you can get to
New York in 14 milliseconds. Well,
you've got one millisecond
where you know the future,
you know exactly what's going to happen.
You're not even betting at this point.
This is easy money.
So what happened over time was a race of
people to provide the straightest fiber
line between Chicago, New York. That's
Mike Bellar again from trademarks.
He's part of this race. A couple
of years ago a company came along,
not his unfortunately and
spent some eight figures,
some to cut a straighter fiber line
between those two points. And um,
according to some reports
they blew through a mountain
to do it. They did a lot.
And where the state of the
art for communication lines
at the time between the
two locations was about 15
and a half milliseconds.
They came along and they made that
state of the art 13.3 milliseconds,
a savings of about one millisecond
each way, which is just an,
it's just a aeon is a thousands of
the second you're talking about.
That's not well it's an Ian.
When your sis computer system is able
to make a decision in 10 microseconds,
which ourselves, that's 10 times
faster. So your computer's like,
I can do this so fast while
I'm just waiting, waiting,
waiting for the news for Chicago.
So a lot of us were sitting around
thinking what can we do about this?
Turns out there was a way to get from
Chicago to New York a little faster
because the speed of light through air,
it's a little faster than when you're
going through a fiber optic cable.
And so what they're doing now is they're
building a series of towers so they can
beam the signal through the air
from one tower to the next tower,
to the next tower, all the way
from Chicago to New York. So,
and that would bring the travel time down
to about in the neighborhood of around
eight and a half milliseconds. You
going from 13 to eight and a half? Yeah.
That would be going from
this to this. I mean come on.
That's a lot of potential savings.
You can totally hear the difference.
Is it helping? Is it, are we
fast enough now? Can we stop?
Um, here's the thing.
That's minnows neuron and
the CEO of trade works.
He joined us for part of the interview
and he told us actually we would love to
stop this arms race. Yeah, absolutely.
The arms racist and huge drain on
resources, but he says, we just can't,
as it stands when a new technology
comes out that makes it possible to be
faster. If I don't adopt it and my
competitors do, I will lose out to them.
I have to do it. And looking
at Minaj in particular,
you could kind of tell it this part of
the job. It's just like the plumbing.
Yeah. Just kind of makes them
weary. Yeah. Couldn't care less.
Why not just call a
truce and everyone say,
we're not going to try and go faster.
We're already way faster than any
human can think. It's fast enough.
We're going to stay up all a truce.
There's a such thing in game theory
called prisoner's dilemma. Um,
and someone will cheat, you're
saying. Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
You can't put a gun to everyone's head
and forced them to abide by this truth,
even though we'd all be better off if
you could. Well, who would be better off
and here Minosh told us, look, even
though the speed race sucks for us,
it's actually helping you
because on a basic level,
anytime you replace a human with a
computer, things are going to get faster.
They're going to get cheaper and
now that the machines are competing,
getting cheaper still in 1992 it would
have cost you about a hundred dollars to
trade a thousand shares. Now 10 bucks.
So yes,
humans have been completely supplanted
when it comes to short term trading and
humans who complain about that are
being disingenuous. Okay. They,
they have not been displaced by anything
other than the fact that they can't
compete. You seem like you've
had to, you seem defensive.
Well, just because I can explain the
economics of the business don't make me
defensive. [inaudible]
that also sounded defensive
if Menashe did sound defensive.
It's only because he and Mike and everyone
in their industry have had to answer
a lot of questions over the past few
years about where all this speed is taking
us and those questions always
come back to one particular day.
May Six 2010
when things got a little fruity.
We hadn't had a down
day in a long while. We,
the market had been slowly creeping
up for quite a while in there.
That's Eric Hahn, Sandra again,
the analyst who's been tracking high
frequency trading. He says, that day,
even though things had been
going really well that day,
it started off down pretty hard,
which made some sense because there
was bad news coming out of Athens.
People were nervous, but then
at a very specific moment,
two 42 in the afternoon,
1442 and 44 seconds,
all hell breaks loose.
Okay, Neil, let me just,
let me just interrupt for a second because
this market is dropping precipitously
adjustment, negative 500
it is now negative 560
[inaudible] on the screen. The
Dow was losing about 653 points.
Now Dow was down 707 points.
[inaudible] boom. There it goes. Look at
this market. It continues to slide up.
Gat At 835 [inaudible] in here.
Now it's down 900 wow. Almost
a thousand points. Yes.
We'll keep you out in a big way
like you had to do with the Gel.
All orders down at
Dalton tights, Chantelle,
two 45 and 27 seconds and
emergency circuit breaker shuts off
for five seconds and that was
the end of the, when it went out
and stopped for five seconds,
that was the bottom of the market.
1000 points down,
several hundred billion dollars
finished two and a half minutes
equally weird when trading started again.
Okay.
The market's bounced right back up.
About two and a half minutes later,
it was 600 points higher than the
bottom. It was like food buying.
Now, these kinds of swings had
happened before, but never that fast
and the speed is one thing.
Arguably what's more troubling
is that we still two
and a half years later,
don't really know what happened.
I mean the SEC investigated for months
released this giant 84 page report where
they essentially blamed the whole thing
on one bed algorithm that this guy in
New York was trying to sell a bunch
of stocks, told his computer to do it.
His computer just did it a
little too aggressively. No,
that's not how it went down
at all. Eric doesn't agree.
He thinks what happened is that all the
high frequency computers just clogged
the network.
Really the cause of the flash crash was
system overload because he says a basic
feature of these computer algorithms is
when they detect the network is slow,
they pull out, you know,
one of the maxims on the street is
when the doubts stay out or pull out.
And so if you've got this one computer
is selling a ton of stock and no
computers left to buy,
that creates a vacuum.
Now there were people who argued that
high frequency trading had actually made
the situation better because you know,
Andrew says the markets did
bounce back right up to the top.
It computers self corrected perhaps.
But the point is nobody had any idea
and that's what gets him that we're in a
situation now where when things go wrong,
they go wrong in the blink of an eye
and then it takes us years to figure out
what happened.
The question that comes up is how have
we crossed some kind of Rubicon where
we've passed into a realm
where the complexities speed,
the volume of all of this stuff
makes it no longer human readable.
We just don't know what the system is
doing and can't in principle find out when
things go wrong.
[inaudible]
if you're having a hard time picture
just how fast and furious high speed
trading is. Check out the visualizations
we've got at radio lab dot who are,
they are strangely beautiful
in a trippy sort of way.
You can also hear how fast they go by
listening to a piano riff that turns one.
Stocks Buy and sell orders
into a string of musical notes.
That's at radiolab.org big thanks
to David [inaudible] for joining me.
If you don't listen to NPRs planet money,
you definitely should definitely
check them out at npr.org/money
and a thanks to Chris Baroo bay carried
a heavy load with the reporting on the
segment and also sound artist Ben Reuben
who lent us the sound of those floor
traders.
Hey Radio, this is Adam in Toronto.
Radiolab is supported in part by
the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
we've been made decrypt.
Well, that was my best
impression of the effect.
Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich.
Radiolab is supported by Sofi,
a new kind of finance
company. Here's the deal.
If you've invested in your career
by taking out student loans,
Sophie wants to help out Sofi, refinances,
federal and private student loans to cut
interest rates and save its members an
average of $316 a month.
Learn more and find your
savings@sofidotcomtermsandconditionsapplyatsofi.com
slash
legal
hey guys, this is Alison
calling from Luxembourg.
Radiolab is supported by rocket
mortgage by quicken loans.
Rocket mortgage brings the mortgage
process into the 21st century.
With this completely online process,
safely share your bank statements and
pay stubs with a touch of a button.
Ditch the paperwork and use your phone
or tablet to get approved for purchase or
refinance in minutes.
Get a custom mortgage solution
whenever and wherever you want.
Check out rocket mortgage
today@quickenloansdotcomslashradiolabequalhousinglenderlicensedinallfiftystatesandmlsconsumeraccess.org
number 30 30
hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I am, I would
call it just is Radiolab and today.
Do you want to say did today's a speed?
This is a perfect example of
what we've been bumping into.
All our humans are slow. We're just
too slow. But now, yeah. Hello,
this Lena. It is all right.
Now we have a story that should
make us all feel a little better.
Can I just say, I didn't even
think this was remotely possible,
but we're about to talk about and the
heroine of our story is a Lena Vestigo.
How that's that? Is that a hyphenate?
No, that vista go is my middle name.
How is the last name? And
my first name is lean.
So Selena is a physicist at Harvard and
she has done something with speed that
is just remarkable. It's
the only way to say it.
If we sort of step back one,
we asked her to walk us through what she
does step by step because it's totally
worth it.
We start out with a clump
of room temperature sodium
and at room temperature,
sodium is actually a nice shiny metal.
Lena and her team, they take the sodium,
they put it in an oven and heat it
up. Exactly. And as it heats up,
Adam's in the sodium starts
vibrate faster and then faster.
And when the temperature gets to
around 350 degrees centigrade,
the Adams form the vapor
super high pressure.
And then she forces the atoms to this
little pinhole have a little hole in the
source.
So this fins stream of atoms now
comes out of a hole and we hit them,
hit on with a laser beam. So you bang
them right in their pathway? Yes,
kick them in a direction opposite to
their motion and that slows them down.
Excited
and now we can load them into
what we call an optical molasses,
optical molester. This is so
baroque. I love it. In the obstacle,
molasses, the aims, will you be hit
by laser beams from all directions?
Is that your way of like saying
don't go this way, don't go this way.
Don't go this way. Yes. You corner
them in from all angles. Yes.
Then we can get them
to a really slow down.
It feels a little bit like you've
enslaved these Adams. I feel bad for them.
It's going to get worse. Yes,
because then that's not good enough.
Now that she has these Adams trap,
she needs to make them sit as still
cause possible. So she
turns off the lasers
total darkness in the lab
and then we turn on an electromagnet,
use the fact that he used the fact that
the Adams has morning magnets to hold
them in a particular point in
space so they don't all fly apart.
Then we can flip the magnet of this
small Adams and selectively kick out the
hardest. Just the hardest of them.
So they will fly out of the magnet and
we just keep a the lowest energy by
flipping the magnets.
You could say to the,
there's one atom that's a little bit
too jumpy. So you say get out of here,
get out of here
cause you, cause you want just the
quietest Adams to stay. That's right.
So now after all this, Lena
has this teeny little cloud.
Oh 0.1 millimeter in size typically
have just a few million atoms,
like five 10 million. And she says at
this point they're all very, very still.
And because temperature is really
just a measure of speed really.
You know when Adam's are moving
quickly, we call that hot.
When they're moving
slowly, we call that cold.
These atoms because they're so still,
these Adams are really cold,
colder than anything on earth.
Colder than the middle of
empty space. Basically.
These are the coldest things
that have ever been cold. Yeah.
And at that point we have a
totally new state of matter
[inaudible]
and of course she was curious about
this new state of matters. That's right.
I'm a curious lady. And now
we get to the part where, uh,
well this is the whole reason
we're telling you this.
She now decides to poke this.
Adam's basically a center light, Paulson
shoot a beam of light into this called
Adam cloud and see Howard, we ex,
you know, when you have a total in,
what was it that, well, you know,
light fashion hates me. I mean, she says,
here's this thing that goes
671 million miles hour.
Then nothing goes faster than light. And
the question just occurred to her like,
what would happen if I took the fastest
thing in the universe and stuck it into
the coldest thing ever made? Exactly. Yes.
So she points your laser at the attic.
I mean, the laser beam hits a switch.
So here you have this, a light poles
coming in, zooming through space,
then the front edge will
reach our Adam cloud.
And unbelievably the light
poles in that moment goes
from hundred and 86,000 miles
per second to 15 miles per hour.
How are you getting, no. So
the light is going like this,
right?
That's right. Wow. And so
I know Adam cloud. Amazing.
Uh,
and then
it just chugs along really a
little bit at a leisurely speed.
Something that you could, uh,
feed on your bicycle. Yeah.
Maybe ride your bike faster
than the light mean. Exactly.
You can sort of think of this waste
between a bicycle and the light calls.
I mean,
imagine you could just bike next to this
blob of light and you could reach out
and maybe pet it a little bit,
then bike on a head. Uh, but
then you'd be in darkness,
but you can go go maybe to the edge
of the cloud and wait for the lights.
And it's all that when it comes through,
you can just catch it. Well, no,
that you can't catch it because when
the light gets to the other side of the
Adam cloud, the,
the front edge will accelerate back
up to this enormous normal lightspeed
and then
rushes off, scratches out again. Cool.
So here's my, Oh, go ahead. I'm sorry.
So, so if you've got it down to 15, is
that a kind of, uh, a, a like a, uh,
a limit? I mean, can you, can we, we
could, we could bring it, Lord, it's,
it's not a stop light. Can you
actually stop light? We can.
So that laser goes in and doesn't come
out. Yes. I mean you hold it like, uh,
like uh, how do you do that?
Huh? Okay. So what we do is a,
it's actually, okay, so things
get a little technical here,
but basically probably to simply,
Lina has figured out a way to tweak
the properties of this Adam cloud.
She can make it like a brick that like
bounces off of, or she can make it clear.
So like cruises through, in this case,
what she does is she shoots
the light into the Adam cloud.
So we slow it down and then right at
that moment, because it's chugging along,
Chuck Chuck Chuck at 15 miles an hour,
she tweaks the Adam cloud
to make it well thick.
And the light parts will say,
oops. Uh, it'll come to a halt.
Almost like it's frozen
in a block of ice in this
[inaudible]. Yes. It just
sits. Wow. When, when,
when you realize what you done,
did you do a little a Jig or
what did you do? You have?
Oh yeah, that
was amazing. They were just like
sitting in the lab of course,
in the middle of the night
and just knowing, Whoa,
you're the first one who has been in
this part of nature. Yeah, it was joy
[inaudible]
you know, of course, to
some extent I'm an engineer,
but this whole idea that I can take
this light poles and bring it down to a
human scale, that something you just, uh,
at a very personal level
gets excited about.
This is more like, you know,
I mean, you can sort of say a,
you know, like, like, like, like, uh,
a sculpturer will create
a beautiful sculpture.
For me, as I was thinking about this,
I actually think of it in terms of
painting, like Vermeer, you know,
the painter,
he could create this illusion that light
was just suspended there on the canvas.
Just shimmering. Yeah. You
Timo captured the light,
but that was just an illusion.
Lena actually did it. Yes.
[inaudible]
do you ever, do you ever wonder,
do you ever like, you know,
after this night you walk out and into
the log and I imagine next day and the
sun is shining and you just
look at the light and you think,
Oh, I've got your number. You're like
Zeus. No. You could resist for a moment.
Uh Huh. Uh Huh. And also
perhaps being Scandinavian,
right where we left the
a light around midsummer.
Yeah. You have a whole lot of it or
then a whole lot. Yes. Yeah, yeah.
Maybe you could do something about that.
Maybe you could store the
hay for the winter time.
You could store it up and then you could
unleash the cloud and suddenly there
would be sunshine when there was other,
and there's darkness. So save it.
Save it for the wintertime.
Yes. Yeah. Well,
we've been doing this
for a number of years.
This is the one in the for
remarkable conversations.
Thank you very much.
This is wonderful. Yeah,
but you didn't [inaudible] real
important. Oh wait, whoa, whoa, whoa.
So, um, we, we can play a trick.
The trigger this we can stop
and extinguish the light
person one part of space
and we vive it in a totally
different location. Yeah,
you can transport hands port it. Yeah.
At this point we were like,
what weird ass science fiction
movie did we just slip into?
Lena says when the light hit those
atoms back in her cloud there,
it's like pulse cloud will create
a little imprint in the arms.
It's like if you were to punch soft clay
with your hand and then you could see
the imprint of your
knuckles there in the clay.
That's what happens when
the light hits those atoms.
The light poles will change
the items a little bit.
That's how it imprints its information
in the Adams and according to Lena,
that imprint, it's like a
physical impression of the light.
All the information about the light,
it's frequency, energy, whatever.
All that stuff is copied in the Adams.
So with this shadow of [inaudible],
does that mean it's a shadow of
light? Yes. And now we can put poulet
imprint out.
So now what we have out in free
space is a perfect Matta copy.
You mean like physical matter? Yes,
and then we can move that around.
We can put it under shell
for, we can move it around,
we can squish it and then we can take
it all. She says if she wants to,
she can then make a few tweaks
to the cloud. Then delight,
pulse will come back to life,
propagate slowly through the cloud
and then exit and speed back up.
So you could store, I mean if you were,
if you were President Obama and
you said, I would like to put it,
put the light around me right now in a
time capsule for later generations to
experience. He could take
it using your process,
put it in an archive somewhere and then
putting in a bottle and thousand years
later they would, they would know the
light that surrounded him. Yes. No,
that's what she said.
How would you know that different
light is the same? How do you know? Oh,
that's the same light.
So it's a contained in my medical
copy that preserves the information.
So when the new light turns on,
it identically copies the light
from before in a way that will,
that makes it as as
specific as saying, that's
Mary Kay Jones again.
Yes, that's right. Oh Man.
I've also also also wonder about,
you know, because we could,
in our lab in Cambridge, we could send
the lay person stab at extinguish it,
make our little medicard. We put it in
a bottle. I could put it in a suitcase,
say bring it to a Copenhagen, turn it
into light. But I've thought about also,
how do I get that bottle?
So security in the airport,
what would it look like? Would it just
be a bottle full of a full of emptiness?
It would be a vacuum, but there would
be a little clump of atoms in there.
What would have to be less than three
ounces of Adams or they would have both.
Yes. So much less than three hours. Yeah.
You could just walk through the April.
You've got no problem. Yeah. Okay.
Oh, you can open and be like,
you want to do some cool blind him.
And that would probably be
also against the law. Yes, yes.
How am I going to get my light
through security?
[inaudible]
if you want to keep the momentum going,
check out our short called speedy beat.
It's about Beethoven and
his apparent need for speed.
Most orchestras don't play
his work anywhere near as
fast as he may have wanted.
Go listen@radiolab.org and while you're
there you can watch a string quartet
play Beethoven's fifth at warp speed.
Seriously, it sounds like speed metal.
No. Six. Hi,
I'm Chris [inaudible] from the radio
at the turn Collagen with the credit.
I actually don't have enough credits
on this phone to try and do this again,
very fast. Regular lab
is actually, well, I'll,
I'll try really, really fast. Video
lab is produced by Ghetto Vermont.
Our staff includes Alan Horn from to
[inaudible] dot com Keith. All right guys,
this is harder than I thought on Keith.
Man. Let me and Andy Mills with Hellman,
Douglas Smith, Chris [inaudible]. I was
looking at Kelsey Patrick pat first.
Thanks. Josh.
Latinas copied in and craft works in a
very special tasks outpatient department.
I found that even though I just read
that very gray pat call probably cost me
about $20 hope you guys use it
on the air and this message.
That's me. I was looking
at Kelsey, Patrick, Megan.